welcome to this video this is a
15-minute game and playing our seed or
off very high rated for 15 minute and
it's a yes it's not a new account or
anything did I plane before yeah played
him once in 15 minute the statistic
tells me enter for a win let's see yeah
well got the scotch scotch opening where
Bishop before check as my pet line yeah
I'll do that Jack I am have quite some
experience by now with this okay well
here beat exeis the way to go and now
Bishop to d3 young Queen edge for is the
move that I'd like to play but it's um
it's tricky Greenidge for Queen d2 to
answer Knight f6 with h3 yeah yeah I
still always feel tempted to play the
move anyway I always liked a lot don't
you Adam that it said this is a bit
questionable but um I still like it I
can't account Albert Knight f6 thurs h3
intending g3
there is also d6 here d6 night is having
something like that and now wonder maybe
I should start with that ok let's start
with this move and see what happens
white as many possible moves of course
it can still play this age 3 move to
prepare g3 to kick the Queen but there
are also moves like 92 which looks very
young very normal try to harass the
Queen with nida three ok but maybe Emma
actually may be threatening while
threatening is a bit much but Bishop g4
in a way he cannot play a threesome in a
way this is um there's this kind of a
threat at least
still no I like 92 Bishop g4 they you
play we probably can't even play Knight
f3 mmm Chuck not sure 92 looks very
normal white can also play on a move
like Bishop to e3 which is a very very
solid way to play but probably not going
not as promising as other continuations
of course you can also consider to
Castle but the ship g4 is a nice move to
get in with temple Bishop g4 the 90 of 6
is pretty good development and there is
some peace play on the King so and I was
taking a while it's not so easy in this
position you can consider quite a number
of options I like 92 I guess I would
play 92f to get the knight to f3 or h3
this is probably a still a good move
yeah g3 there's always Queen a tree this
is just not good i believe it we can
some whites kingside enormously yeah age
30 92 would be my preference why is
taking a really long time yes it's not
disconnected sometimes it happens so
gotta disconnect and then it takes ages
before the the platform actually
registers the disconnect but he's just
taking a very long time what else is
there maybe more 'if I've could be a
month maybe in be five and no e five
this Bishop g4 I am this is really
really bad yeah can also think about be
four or a four to complete the the
number of candidate moves a form would
threat okay it's going for that which is
very as mentioned a very solid way to
play I'll think I just take it or not I
could play Bishop g4 still winning
winning a temple and wow yeah it would
also get the Queen to a somewhat
uncomfortable square okay esta la I
still like that it's a very simple way
to play I can develop now Knight f6 d500
g-form completely completely wrong
and I have Nigel possibly 95 now yeah
Bishop e3 was somewhat tame way to play
it it should not pose any substantial
problems to to black and this Knight g4
business is really a bit bit annoying
especially something like let's say
castle it's noisy for it some already
bit tricky for white are threatening
them threatening the media and okay can
play Queen g3 but I can exchange and put
the knight to e5 okay let's think about
it should I play 94 getting getting
Queens off it pretty much exchanges
Queens as Queen g3 is the only real
answer that's probably just the right
length what can you do Queen D for the
c5 that's completely completely wrong
and yeah here this is of course a
possible move I thought 95 now looks
like a good a good response putting this
night right in the middle of the board
mmm that is bit unexpected
oh ok
hmm sure to a 6 mm it feels wrong what
what what is this Bishop doing on a six
I have Bishop g4 this is 11 pretty good
move against it you cannot go f3 give me
he must move the Queen basically and
it's not like there are many many very
good squares I can also think about
taking and then move like Queen to g5
the text g2 white cannot what cannot
castle as the night is hanging might
castle long yeah that's actually a good
move okay so
and this Bishop g4 stuff
yeah I wonder I wonder takes takes Queen
g5 long castles him probably Quincy to
looks very very shaky
I'm not sure if I'm what to do with this
should i take it yeah I'll take it
what's really am a bit unsure
the night is very nice on you 5 i'm not
sure how to continue here would like to
play move like winter fall or something
playing him attacking the two so that he
cannot easily castle yeah if I just
cancel
not bad i can just castle it's not not
bad at all if he castles there is even
f4 available maybe f5 I mean lon Kellow
castles castles f5 the writers got a
form which is a bit bit annoying I'll
activate the Queen iam so he cannot
Castle short because it hangs you cannot
cancel long because f 2 eggs so he will
do something else g3 there is no boo 33
the problem is g3 Knight f3 takes Queen
takes there are screen Texas 6 which is
such as a a very serious issue
and like of course I didn't I didn't see
any of that this is not not good not
good at all yeah what do i do go into
Queen here probably if he goes FY and
premise play Knight f3 Knight f3 check
takes Queen takes Queen c6 check Quincy
6 check Cham King d8 probably takes on
the edge check king d 7 takes on a jade
and I can take f1 and h1 completely
crazy maybe that's a draw something
hmmmm not good yeah but eboolin I mean
he will play a f4 I am pretty sure or is
there a lot every castles I can do
something like winter c8 just getting
this kind of tempo on the Queen so that
I'm much more secure again ok f for
checking guide takes Queen takes a three
Queen takes c6 check king is seven ok he
is canceling probably probably a wise
decision ok I can play Queen here
I can play the Queen all the way back I
could also try to play a wacky move like
g5 try to make sure that this night
stays on d5 okay can play moon I have
this check on any night move g5f three
then I can still play Quincy 8am i wanta
care I'm I'm doing that I'm doing that
remove that I can also consider at some
point is keen to d7 looks a bit crazy
but why not it connects the rooks and it
protects c6 c7 very very complicated
position
yeah everything is completely dependent
on this night position on e5 if my night
stays there and it's not in any way I'm
a liability I'm perfectly fine but it
might still be a problem I came let's
see here i can drop all the way back to
see a diff i like it's not bad actually
so pretty at the end game would be would
be pretty ok at least nothing terrible
to fear but it's a bit of a lame move
really I go to e6 mf4 takes takes rook
g8 check King off to h1 and then then
the noid alright does not have a good
square I cannot really that's no way to
finish right off really um yeah I would
like to go to e6 as an ID c4s also
prevented with that but f4 f4 looks
tricky I mean it looks it looks
exceptional risky but don't really see a
justification at the moment okay I need
to play this I drop all the way back I
am expected something like Queen to a4
maybe trying to keep some pressure on c6
and keeping Nyjah seaforth in the
position
if he exchanges queens i think i should
be all right I mean it's no reason why
black should be a verse in this position
after the Queen trade okay went all the
way back probably Quincy for a night c4
ok but not c4 I can i can actually play
i can actually play 26 should be all
right now of course try to make use of
my rook on the edge farm
replace f form I can maybe take G pawn
takes and Queen g4 check could be could
be a possibility
f-for looks fairly logical though I mean
tried to play against them my best piece
only five maybe this is an idea night c4
and Queenie 692 III could be trying to
get it to a 5 but I get an age form okay
I don't want to spend any more time
trying to to not fall so far behind on
the clock night III g4 there's F 493
check rook takes a three exchanging the
sacrificing the exchange for tremendous
compensation so on 93 I cannot really
play G form okay he chose the the simple
way to play okay when FYI also had this
intermediate check should I take first
yeah maybe think first and now well I
can also insert this check which I'm not
sure about really or should I just go
here can I go I go to see if I first and
let's see now 5f d5 it's probably not
you know if I've there's also quit if I
check question is how to coordinate my
books rook bh this
something not sure like to double of
course on the G file the G file is the
open file yeah i'm not sure i have only
have four minutes all better get i get
going yeah i have to slightly worse pawn
structure but not quite sure if this is
served any importance a direct idea of
rugby a discreet to be five possibly and
taking on be a while this is surprising
really he allows me to go to deform okay
maybe just protects it still it's a bit
of a surprising move maybe maybe he
wants to go I five
you fired two to open up the center
hmm yeah certainly possible okay need to
connect the rooks there is simply no way
around that the King might get a check
off from age three here this is my B but
my next move will be rookie eight anyway
and see what I can do against the you
for bond yeah I can play at five just a
brutally attacking it now that's it's
not that's really a that's really an
idea after years played c4 and b3 my
king would even have quite a spotty on
b7 it's not not completely completely
off ok on to use the open false that's
not bad here this position it should be
okay for me
okay okay that this is check on f5 this
is what he wants to do but this King is
also very open check my key won't be 7s
is quite ok ok let's see how can he take
here he can but I have if I protect
maybe this isn't getting the rook here
maybe rook g8 and Queen f7 I can take
you five so that should be should be ok
well maybe I can get something against
this king my king is quite ok now really
on b7 and he is getting very short on
time now at least I have some some
minutes some minutes extra yes but I
don't want to exchange queens now i can
check here so some way not to trade
queens would really prefer that if
possible
Rock d 4 + x totally ridiculous a self
pin but it's not looking for may be
known
hmm yeah I don't want to trade Queens
really how to avoid it I can do to a
five maybe maybe a terrible decision I
don't know when Cree trade was ok no
problem or anything this is just a bit
of a gamble and now it's going to rock
III
137 yes I saw that I wanted to wanted to
this I didn't see Oh Chang this was this
wasn't a good gamble no I completely
spoiled this position it was perfectly
ok I should have just traded queen seon
unbelievable
okay it's still not not easy at all to
play my new i will need to get to the
forms here time morning yeah it's just a
very bad position Queen f8 okay can I
afford queen d 50 s is just lost don't
know
it's probably just lost right 19 seconds
and no and now overlook this bloody move
know ah ok black resign yeah look dat
can just take why this was bad this was
really bad i mean yeah i was i was scam
bling a bit too much him I mean rookie
fibers just just completely okay but
it's also not good for black I was
hoping on his bed king position and try
to to keep the Queen's Own but it's
probably it's probably not not really
good the the real problem was I thought
about this and wanted to go here but
this is just nonsense because of rookie
em and while the queen is just not not
well placed on the queenside I was just
I was just playing for too much I really
have no problem yeah this is just a good
position no problem whatsoever and ah
this is a ground for f6 this is a strong
wow this would have said in lots of lots
of problems I problem is what is White's
move now you cannot take us just losing
instantly check this as well or you
cannot really take in any way if white
was play something like this and to try
to keep the balance probably
successfully but ok this was a strong
move rookie for was it was possible but
here Mia and I just must I just must
take him this
is something like this is just just okay
there's nothing happening really just
just equal yeah well have 11 minutes
more on the clock so I wanted to try to
keep it complicated and here must
probably take em I didn't see c5 at all
and this is this gets really tricky now
uh-huh the computer wants to take on b5
i have ever before okay yeah then this
is them then that's still ok for me
actually I can take here there's nothing
too terrible happening that's okay yeah
then I must take after that I'm probably
just lost him I mean okay probably
didn't play it the best way possible
with this minute on the clock but it's
it's just a win yeah this is too much to
the poor nearly seven now I'd probably I
mean I actually had f6 this was 11
possibility and okay I could have
defended better but probably it just
does not make much sense to avoid the
Queen trade there is something so
there's not not not much happening here
it's just a normal position completely
completely yeah unclear in a way its own
but it should be a with mutual chances
check here this f6 move this is a strong
move
yeah this is probably saving the day
avoid getting a pawn back yeah I didn't
didn't see that this would have would
have helped yeah it was a very very
complicated game anyway well not not
quite sure about many things here what
I'd like to know is after this this f4
should be ok right I wasn't sure at all
check this year check Garrett said
that's a draw the computer gives it in
the drop yeah this is my suspicions that
we both um check that we can can play
this is this is a perpetual check check
check check check check here checked out
here should be a perpetual right check
check yeah I guess I just check in and
queen be [ __ ] up it's so it's a
perpetual yeah a bit of a shame i should
have really played them played the pre
trade check check yeah my problem was I
wanted to go here and thought well the
Queen comes back somehow and tries to
harass his king but there's this rookie
three move and this makes the whole
procedure useless I cannot take care of
course because of rupee 3 all right but
it was interesting game I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching